Okay.
So before yesterday's Robert Mueller testimony,
I outlined for you that Donald Trump went
on a tweet storm, uh, melting down completely
with 10 tweets and a period of just a few
hours, very, very clearly panicked about what
was then the upcoming testimony of Robert
Mueller.
Uh, my, uh, prediction was at the time, Trump
is not going to listen to the substance and
even if he does, he's not really going to
understand it because he does have significant,
uh, significantly compromised comprehension
abilities.
Trump is going to go by tone.
Molar was sort of slow.
Mueller was sorta forgetful.
Mueller appeared sort of confused.
So Donald Trump was going to come away thinking
that he won just bigly because of yesterday's
at Robert Mueller's testimony.
That is exactly the case.
Donald Trump does believe that he won that.
He came out unscathed by yesterday's molar
testimony and we're going to look at some
of Donald Trump's reactions.
Now I'm not going to Redo the first segment
from today's show.
I already outlined for you the endless ways
in which Robert Mueller's testimony on the
fact, not on the tone confirmed that Donald
Trump is absolutely impeachable at minimum
more than enough evidence to start an impeachment
inquiry.
But right now I want to focus on Donald Trump's
reaction.
Now, before I get into some of the video,
it is actually sad and horrifying that our
president so severely lacks comprehension
skills to understand the substance of what
Robert Mueller confirmed yesterday, which
is that Trump is impeachable.
Trump came out thinking it was a great day
for him.
Let's look at some clips starting with Donald
Trump's kind of big picture conclusion that
Mueller just had nothing to say because Donald
Trump did nothing wrong.
I think Robert Mueller did a horrible job
both today and with respect to the investigation,
but in all fairness to Robert Muller, he had
nothing to work with.
You know, you can be a builder, but if they
don't give you the right materials, you're
not going to build a very good building.
Robert Muller had no material.
He had nothing to work with, so obviously
he did very poorly today.
This might be the most disconnected one could
be from the content of the hearing.
Mueller confirmed obstruction.
Mueller confirmed Trump directed his lawyer
to lie.
Mueller confirmed Trump can be indicted after
leaving the White House.
Mueller confirmed that investigations are
ongoing.
Mueller confirmed that as damaging as his
report was, the scope was so limited that
it didn't even explore multiple areas of wrongdoing
by Donald Trump.
Mueller confirmed that Trump's actions meet
all three legal requirements to be considered
obstruction on multiple counts.
Mueller confirmed that Trump was untruthful
in his written answers to investigators.
Now I could go on and on, but only someone
who does not understand what he saw or is
lying could come away with the conclusion
that Donald Trump purports to have come away
with.
Once again, here's another piece from earlier
in Donald Trump's little statement where he
again summarizes everything as it was just
lovely for me.
So we had a very good day today, the Republican
Party, our country.
There was no defense of what Robert Mueller
was trying to defend.
In all fairness to Robert Butler, whether
his performance was a bad one or a good one.
I think everybody understands that.
I think everybody understands what's going
on.
There was no defense for this ridiculous hoax
is witch hunt that's been going on for a long
time.
Pretty much from the time I came down on the
escalator with our first lady, and it's a
disgrace what happened.
What I think today proved a lot to everybody.
In fact, some of my biggest opponents wrote
things today that I wouldn't have believed
I would have written, and I appreciate that
they did that.
This might be the height of confusion Trump
claimed since day one that the report exonerated
him and thanked Mueller for it and went on
nationwide exoneration tour events on the
basis of Mueller supposedly exonerating him,
which molar didn't do.
In the hearing, Mueller confirmed I did not
exonerate Donald Trump.
Now Donald Trump has shifted completely and
is saying, oh yeah, Mueller never had the
right to exonerate me.
Well then why did you go on an exoneration
to her on the basis of what you believed was
an exoneration from Robert Mueller, which
it wasn't.
Take a look at this.
So there is no section thing.
He didn't have the right to exonerate ad.
You know, it's very interesting people mention
exoneration.
That was something where he totally folded
because you never had the right to exonerate
and it was covered very well by Congressman
Turner.
Add what to I conclusion we were, if you take
a look at not only the report beyond the report,
take a look at not what he said, but what
he was forced to say.
Why did you use what you falsely believed
to be an exoneration from Mueller as evidence
of your innocence.
If your new position is Mueller actually have
the right to exonerate me at all.
So then attempting to bring Donald Trump back
to reality, which is tough to do.
Some reporters actually started pressing Trump
a little bit on hold on a second.
Uh, one example, Mueller said, you were untruthful
in your written answers and Trump just buries
his head in the sand and says, no, not booboo.
I wasn't untruthful.
You were untruthful to the reporter and I
wish I was kidding when I said that.
This is effectively what Donald Trump did.
But here is Donald Trump telling the reporter
that she's the one who's lying.
Can you imagine anything more childish?
What about what about mother's Day and that
you're getting your answers truthful.
What do you say to that, Aiden?
Say That at all.
You're untruthful when you actively said you
are untruthful.
When you asked that question when you asked
that question, you're on truth phone.
You can say Mueller was too reserved.
You can say Mueller was meek.
You can say Mueller appeared confused, but
Mueller was very direct and clear on the issues.
Trump did not tell the truth in the written
answers.
We already discussed that in the first segment.
So first and foremost, this is a president
who is completely disconnected from reality.
Who thinks he came off looking great after
Robert Mueller confirmed impeachable wrongdoing
by Donald Trump during the hearing.
But take a step back for a second.
Does anyone realize how dangerous it is to
have a president whose comprehension is so
compromised that this is what he took away
from the Mueller hearings?
Let's assume for a second that Trump isn't
lying here and he genuinely thinks the Mueller
hearings were just great for him.
Even though Mueller confirmed impeachable
behavior by Donald Trump.
What is Trump taking away from intelligence
briefings?
If this is how much his, how significantly
his comprehension is compromised?
What is Trump gleaning from meetings with
foreign leaders if he can watch what not Robert
Mueller said yesterday and think that he got
away unscathed, his comprehension is completely
compromised and he's the president of the
United States.
Aside from more immediate decisions, Democrats
are going to have to make about impeach or
not impeach or whatever else.
This is a danger
and I want to hear from you about it.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show.
Please follow both accounts t